how do we solve a system of linear
equations using matrices and
determinants how do we solve for the
values of x and y here so one way is by
solving them using one of the regular
techniques we have seen or we can use
matrices to solve them yes matrices to
solve the equations using matrices and
determinants we first need to write them
in the matrix form so we first write the
matrix of the coefficients for the first
equation the coefficients are two and
minus one and for the second the
coefficients are three and two this is
the matrix of coefficients of the two
variables and for this will be
multiplied with the matrix which has the
column of variables the variables are x
and y so a matrix with the coefficients
multiplied with a matrix with a column
of variables and this product is equal
to a matrix with a column of the
constants on the right hand side that
will be 4 and 13 this is the matrix form
of the above system of equations why do
we say that this is the matrix form we
will know why when we multiply these two
matrices
do you remember multiplication of
matrices to know if two matrices can be
multiplied we need to check their order
the order of this matrix is 2x2 and that
of this one is two by one two rows two
columns and two rows one column as the
second and the third numbers are the
same these matrices are compatible for
multiplication the order of the
resulting matrix will be the first
number by the fourth number it will be
two by one so we multiply the first row
of this matrix with the first column of
this matrix and write the product here
and then multiply the second row of this
matrix with the first column of this
matrix and write the product here what
will be the product of these two it will
be 2x minus y and the product of these
two will be 3x plus 2y this is the
product of these two matrices and this
matrix will be
as is now you see why this is the matrix
form of the system of equations as these
two matrices are equal we can say that
2x minus y will equal 4 and 3x plus 2 y
will equal 13 same as these two
equations but let's come back to the
important point
how does writing it in matrix form help
us solve the equations let's see that on
the right hand side this can be written
as a times X is equal to B we have
called this one matrix a and this matrix
X and this matrix B a times X is equal
to B what we're interested in is matrix
X that will give us the values of
variables x and y so to get X on the
left hand side we multiply both sides
with a inverse we get the left-hand side
as a inverse times a X and the right
hand side as a inverse times B now a
inverse times a will equal the identity
matrix we get this and we know that the
identity matrix times any matrix will
give us that same matrix so the
left-hand side will equal matrix X and
the right-hand side will be a inverse
times matrix B that's how we get matrix
X we multiply a inverse with B so when
we are given the two equations we write
it in this form find the inverse of this
matrix and multiply it with this to get
matrix X and that will give us the
values of the variables we will solve
this example in the next lesson